Hey everybody, and welcome back to
FP101x - Functional Programming.
What we're going
to do today is taking the first
baby steps in learning Haskell.
One of my favorite movies of all time
is the Karate Kid and if you haven't
seen this movie,
stop watching
this lecture and go watch this movie
first.
Every time I need to learn something new,
I rewatch the Karate Kid
and I can tell you... I've seen it
maybe
20-30 times and every time I watch it,
I learn something new.
If you
watch the movie, you will see that
the boy here, Daniel, wants
to learn karate
and mister Miyagi, the gentleman
here
on the other side, makes him do a
lot of
what Daniel thinks are pointless
exercises. And he gets kind of frustrated.
But in order to learn something you have
to go
through a lot of exercises because
there's a lot of muscle memory or, in
case of programming you have to have the
muscle memory in your fingers. They're
certain things should not have to think
about.
That you have to drill. That you have to
do over and over and over again.
And that's what we are going to do in
this lecture today.
So don't get frustrated, don't be like
Daniel.
Be a grownup and just do your exercises
on and on: wax on wax off, wax on, wax off...
until it becomes completely automatic
and then you can use your brain to solve
the real problem.
You don't have to think about the basics
anymore. And every time you learn
something new
rewatch this great movie.
Let's show some Haskell. The Haskell implementation
that we're using
in this course is the Glasgow Haskell
Compiler
sometimes also called the Glorious
Haskell Compiler
and GHC is the leading implementation of
Haskell.
It has both a compiler and an
interactive
REPL loop that you can use to type in
your
code.
The interactive nature
of the GHC interpreter makes it really
easy
to experiment with Haskell
and that's why it's also very useful for
this course.
Many of the exercises
that you will get during the course, you
can do
by using GHC.
I don't
see that as cheating because
as programmers, we should really use the
compiler
to help us. The computer is there
to help us program the computer.
If we don't use that, that would be
stupid. GHC
is freely available from the website
here. The link will be also be on the
course website, and you can also
Google or Bing for the Haskell platform
and it's available for all major
platforms
Mac, Windows and Linux.
To start GHC,
you just type from the command line 'ghci'
and then you get some
text blurps and there you see a prompt
Prelude> and that's where you can start
typing in
expressions. For example we can type in
the expression
2 + 3 * 4 and
GHCi will then print the result for that.
In this case we're really using
GHCi as kind of a calculator.
It's a little bit like a calculator
on the command line interface,
instead of a calculator with buttons.
What we also see here is that since
2 + 3 * 4 apparently is 14
that multiplication binds stronger
than addition. So there's no surprises
there as
most languages have that.
If we want to
first do the addition and then
the multiplication, we have to put
parentheses, so we write
(2 + 3) * 4
and then the result is 20.
We can do
more complicated expressions like the
square root of (3 ^ 2 + 4 ^2)
and we get 5.
As you saw, there was the
Prelude>
prompt
here. So the Haskell Prelude it's like
the SDK for Haskell. These are all the
standard functions
that come for free with Haskell.
On the website
we will tell you how to get
other libraries for Haskell,
but we won't discuss that in too much
detail right here. You
you can read up on that.
We will
will try to stick with just the
standard library functions - the standard
prelude.
A lot of the functions in the prelude
are functions over lists.
We're going to walk through a
couple of them and then in later lectures
we will implemented these functions in
several different
manners. The first function here is head,
which takes a list,
and the way we write lists in Haskell
is with square brackets and the
elements separated by commas,
so the head of [1,2,3,4,5] is
unsurprisingly 1.
The tail,
that's the opposite of head, so is
everything on the list
except the head, so the tail of [1,2,3,4,5]
is the list [2,3,4,5].
We can also select
the n-th element of the list with
this
double exclamation mark operator.
If we want to select the second element
of the list
[1,2,3,4,5] we get
3. So what do we learn from this?
Well...
that the first element of the list
has index 0.
Haskell starts
indexing lists by zero.
There's
2 exclamation marks here and there's
a good reason for that:
because in Haskell,
lists are not arrays,
so indexing
into the list here at the second
element
will traverse the list. So it
will traverse the list, throw away 1
throw away 2 and then return 3.
This is not a constant time
operation. Indexing into a list, unlike
indexing into an array,
in Haskell is linear in the length
of the list.
In general linear in the size of the
list.
But fortunately
we will hardly see uses
of this operator in practice.
If you find yourself wanting to use list
indexing
then you know that you have not done
enough wax on, wax off, wax on, wax off.
Tou're still too much in the mindset of
imperative programming using arrays.
In Haskell we typically use higher
order functions like map, filter, fold
and not indexing to
perform complex operations over lists.
Here's another
example - take 3 - it takes the first
three elements of a list. If we have
the list [1,2,3,4,5]
it returns the first three
elements
[1,2,3]
Drop
is the opposite, so it takes a number
and a list and it drops the first
three elements of the list. In some
sense, drop
and take are
the generalizations of head and tail.
Head and tail
just take the first and the rest of the
list and then with take and drop
you can generalize that
to arbitrary numbers.
Calculating the length of the list...
we do that by
calling the function length.
Length of [1,2,3,4,5] is 5.
Again, lists in Haskell are not
like arrays
in other languages, so taking the length
is not a constant time operation.
It takes time linearly in the
length of the list.
Sum sums up all the elements so
if we call sum of [1,2,3,4,5]
the result is 15.
Product
is the same as sum, except instead of
adding up the numbers, it
multiplies all of them, so
multiplying
1, 2, 3, 4 and 5 - like taking
the factorial of 5 -
is 120. Appending two lists is another
common operation: you take 2 lists and
you smash them together into a new list,
so if I
append [1,2,3] with [4,5]
we get the list [1,2,3,4,5].
The last function here
on this slide is reversing a list.
Reverse [1,2,3,4,5] gives you
[5,4,3,2,1]
In the rest of
these lectures, we will define all
these functions ourselves
in several ways, but right now
it's good to play with them to
see what they do,
and then we will be ready to
implement them.
Then we will know what they are
supposed to do.
Here's
another very important slide
and that is about function application.
Haskell
is very different than mathematics on
the one side
and very different from other
programming languages as well.
In mathematics when you apply a function -
mathematics that you do in school or
college when you take analysis -
when you apply a function to an argument,
you always use parentheses.
In this case
when we apply a function here...
this is
applying a function f to arguments
a and b
and then adding c
space d.
In mathematics,
typically, and that comes from
physics
is that space means multiplication.
If you look at the mathematical
textbook
and you see c d
it usually means c multiplied by d
and therefore when you apply a function
you're using
parentheses like this to disambiguate.
Since in Haskell
function application is used much more
often
than multiplication,
whereas in physics
multiplication is used more often, so
that's where
multiplication is given the most
white symbol, the least
visible symbol, the most white spacey symbol.
In Haskell,
function application is denoted by white
space
so that it's not so much in
your face.
So in Haskell instead of writing
f (a,b) + c d
function application
becomes
denoted by a space,
so it's f a b + c * d
In most programming languages
you would write
f (a, b) so they are in
some sense the
worst of two worlds: there you
have to write everything explicit.
In Haskell we made the decision that
function application
is done by using a space and
multiplication
is done by using multiplication.
Also,
function application binds stronger
than any other operator.
If you see
f a + b, that means
f applied to a
plus b,
It doesn't mean f
applied to (a + b).
People have to get used to this.
This doesn't mean
f times a plus b.
It means
f applied
to a plus b.
So that's
kind of similar to multiplication binding
stronger than addition.
Here's a table that give you
a couple of more expressions
on the one side Haskell,
and on the other side mathematics.
So this is what you should forget.
I'm going to stand in front of that..this
is what you should forget.
And this is what you should learn.
So forget what's behind me and learn
what's on this side.
Instead of f open parentheses x,
we write
f space x. Instead of passing two
parameters to f
we apply f to x and then
apply that result to y.
Instead of f open parens g, open parens x
we can write
f of g of x and later we'll see
that we can write that using function
composition
as f composed g.
the rest of the examples
should be obvious.
If you just look at
shapes of these two - don't try to
interpret them - you will see that the
Haskell code here
looks much lighter-weight than the code
on this side. Haskell programmers are
lazy - we don't want to type too much -
so this looks much more beautiful
than this
and that's why Haskell's syntax is designed
the way it is.
Thank you!.
This was the end of Part 1.
See you in a bit for the remainder of
chapter 1.